bonjour prima di cominciare il video
raga faccio proprio questa premessa
velocissima lo prometto gli apro e
richiudo la questione di tia taylor
stavolta proprio poi non ne parlo più
perchè bassa ci ha veramente sono saturo
di questa discussione ormai sapete tutto
ciò che penso perché ieri youtube fa
cagare ha fatto un video su questa cosa
condivido alcune cose che ha detto altre
le condivido un po meno perché ci sono
quelle cose che in atto andrebbero un po
più approfondite però vabbè sticazzi
tutto ciò che volevo dire
penso che ormai fosse chiaro che tutto
ciò che io ho detto in quel video non lo
pensavo sul serio cioè nel senso che non
mi permetterei mai di giudicare una
youtube seriamente parlando se non la
conosco neanche pensavo fosse chiara
questa cosa però evidentemente non lo
era e proprio a questo proposito se
dovessi mai fare un video reaction
ancora su un'altra persona mi assicurerò
al mille per cento di dire nello stesso
video che sto scherzando che non ho
nulla contro la persona in questione
come ultima cosa mi dissocio per
l'ennesima e ultima volta da quei
[ __ ] che sono andati a
commentare sotto tia taylor perché non
rappresentano me nei mini fanno
rappresentano un cazzo di niente direi
anche basta perché la ragazza in
questione sta continuando a fare tutto
quello che faceva prima non ne parla
neanche più io non ne voglio parlare più
e altra gente ha voglia di parlare di
questa situazione fa del cazzo che vi
pare io ho finito di discutere di questa
cosa perché penso che ormai sia tutto
ben chiaro chiudo parentesi
cominciamo quel video di oggi i vari
oggi su player non batte il grande sono
con thomas con pietro credo se non mi il
costo se c'è pietro no proverò pietra ed
è il più bel video di player anno che io
abbia mai registrato finora
buona visione
se il nostro eroe alle prese con ovs
cantanta da tanta da pietro tutto bene
nel tuo viaggio in macchina
sì grazie anche nel mio sistema
leggeri
il discorso webcam perché si sta tutto a
posto ma abbiamo alcune arrivato con una
dacia blu in questo posso farti una
domanda ma nun me lo chiedo ma come
cazzo parcheggi è che stavolta
parcheggio è fisicamente impossibile
come parcheggiato così come com'è
possibile
non riesco a fare manovra ma visto
niente lasciava no no no no no perfetto
grande al palazzetto calcolata per fare
ma che occupa di esibizione onora e mi
hanno inviato un po di un mio moderatore
bellissimo per far capire esattamente la
manovra che ho fatto per togliere la tua
macchina a d'amico
siamo lo faccio lo passo il live è
bellissimo c'è uno ci facevano c'è un
aiuto dove c'è dentro dentro c'è uno
dentro 600 che andiamo andiamo dove
andiamo a fare
esatto abbiamo detto di massima a iolo
aspetta la cina è morto è morto così
mica quanta roba aveva mai meglio 49
premio prende allora siamo con il
central high ora si chiude e poi secondo
me si chiude un versatile la ci si parla
a sedere si tutti i sensi colpi da
dietro vengono parag patel
raga fate i bravi che deve vincere la
partita
dietro il casinò cosa stai facendo
guardalo è caduto boom che vi guardo
dietro perché ho paura che qualcuno ci
in gruppi no one in grappe dal sembra un
bel verbo in chrome 47 alive 4 contro 3
3 vivi
eccoli li vedo a 207 minuti
l'affidamento della casa forse posso far
velo ok parità la segnali vengono qua
davanti a me sono qua davanti a me
davanti a membro previsto mirando mi
stanno approcciando dovrà causare tra
poco davanti a te pietro davanti a te la
mente tempo ai lati
quanti sono uno crociato rimangono due
vivi
mica è bravo quali due mediani manca uno
anche quaderni guarda me lo faccio io
eccolo porto tuttora esistente ho visto
ora no no no no no 3 legge di tutti lui
già che c'erano sks incastrato dentro le
scale lo prendo io
un ciclista ce la fate è incastrata
nelle scale la prendo io il prego mi
date un ottica per sks giusta torre nord
per due l'italia non posso dire i due
per due diventano per quattro super
juice forma los andes freaknet ed è
immenso knobloch smoking gli hanno
insegnato negli l'hai vista che brava
l'ho preso due volte in rete la finestra
quale sono saltati giù sono stati sotto
il ragazzo sta bene ma mica tutti è
possibile
ok uno è morto eccole lo vedo scappare
siamo colpito bravo così siamo così
andiamo dal da quel palazzo lanza che
potesse essere anche da quale si c'era
tutta la scalatura per tutto il palazzo
si poneva però c'è la prima rete a
palazzo perché pensi prendere danno sarà
ora che ci sia un evento ne vedo uno
peggio un tempo dell'ora e muoviti
muoviti sias paradis abitando un tizio
muoviti 295 lo vedi guarda con la terza
persona lo vedi la picchia come mi ha
detto di spostarmi sono pagato ad ora
insomma visto che era fermo alla tutto
mi sta minando lui s'è colelli che sta
guardando il soffio dopo dire che non
supera il tetto cinema vero sì magari ci
sta disponendo tra di loro
eccolo lì da uno
uno a destra questo che pone bianco è sì
uno è lì e uno sarà nella quello grigio
di fronte a noi
tra l'altro adesso si fida colpito o
grande ma l'amore ma io la creatura è
dentro è dentro è dentro è sempre dentro
loro uscendo sta scappando dove dietro
capo dietro la casa bianca del tom edito
il capo non è verde adesso ci dà uno
sulla montagna in questo la montagna
sullo spacco montagna solo spacco boom
caro morti morti tutti e tre morti roma
26 mag il tour banana che arma all m
esenzioni price da dietro non seduti
nella stessa non rientra dietro o dove
si mescola non lo so però sono uscito
perché se sarai vediamo una nota casa
arrivano non posso devono prenderà che
dalla montagna a 300 esattamente fa solo
rischio buttar via virgola l'ho colpito
in testa e sopra 300 c'è uno sfondamento
sai eccolo ha scollinato va bene va bene
ma deve riuscire abbiamo in piedi anche
qua e qua qua si aspetta e non sono così
sto passato largo a destra e pietra ma
credo uno morto bravo d'ora vieni verso
soci cc c'è un tizio quas primas è
l'unico che rimane in realtà sa di sì è
un tre contro la sopra di me prima che
muoia prima che muoia loro mi raccomando
ma poi esattamente noi ucciso mez
traditore è la patria schifoso pietro
una cosa non dovevi farmi e proverò a
darti supporto a sparargli più lontano
l'ombra ancora mano che come è andato
bene bene bene bene chi è stata sudata
ma fu ucciso
grazie due vinte in un solo video due
partite genova incredibile mai successo
se non fosse stato per pietro quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto cose
sul momento mi piace anche questo cioè
come giustizia ci siete e noi ci vediamo
da ragazzi
[Musica]